[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
in the spirit of the holidays these are
some awesome tech gifts or just things
to get for yourself for under fifty
bucks now this isn't just a random
collection of things that I found on the
internet that happened to be cheap I'm
gonna actually give you things that I
use in my daily life and that I didn't
even realize we're so awesome until you
guys were asking more about him on
Twitter so these are actually things
that I use day-to-day and I'll leave
links to as many of them as I can right
below and as you guys know these things
also tend to sell out pretty quickly at
their current prices so I'll also try to
leave a sort of a second choice or an
alternative to the first choice should
it sell out so let's just get right into
it so this is the thing I got this all
started it's this little basic simple
Motorola power pack and I was at the
airport a couple of days ago on a trip
and I had this in my bag and charged up
someone else's iPhone and charged up my
Nexus 6 and didn't even have to think
about it much and then just slipped it
in my back pocket this is super simple
and easy I've had it for I guess a long
time and I finally looked it up and it's
called the Motorola power pack slim 4000
now I can easily recommend anyone of
like thousands of battery packs as you
guys know there are tons of them but the
reason why I keep coming back and using
this one over others even of like a
higher capacity is because it has the
USB cable built in so it'll easily
charge any phone that uses a micro USB
cable which is most it also happens to
have a USB port so if you do want to
bring an iPhone cable and charge an
iPhone you can do it that way but I
found that this is the easiest way to
charge basically any Android phone I
just notice my battery's low plug it in
and then slip them both back in my
pocket and it's charging up it is a four
thousand milliamp hour capacity as the
name implies so you can charge basically
any phone from 0% to 100% and then some
and it's just simple basic not too many
buttons or any crazy things like
flashlights on it and the thing is it
was $23 the other day on Amazon so I
tweeted it out because I found it and it
turns out to be really inexpensive then
right after I tweeted the link the price
dropped to $18 so I guess what I'm
saying is get it while it's cheap
there's a couple of other charging
options I've used that I really like -
another one with a built-in cable is
called the travel card it has a 1500
power battery and it's basically the
size of a thick credit card and another
one is this guy the bolt which has a
3000 milliamp hour battery it doesn't
have a built-in cable but it plugs right
into the wall to charge which is really
convenient and I have two of these
actually so I'll have both of these
linked right below that like button
alright another piece of tech is Google
chromecast and I actually don't watch TV
that often in fact they don't pay for a
cable subscription at all but when I do
watch TV it's usually watching an NBA
game through NBA League Pass on a
computer in another room chrome casting
to my TV so if you don't know what
chromecast is I have a separate video
review of it on my channel already but
essentially it turns your regular TV
with an HDMI port into a sort of a
Google Smart TV lets you stream media
lets you stream stuff from Google Chrome
some movies some games YouTube videos
whatever it is it comes from Google
Chrome and for less than 50 bucks it's
awesome and definitely worth it now next
up is a tech accessory it's phone cases
now you guys know how I feel about phone
cases but really it's not all about the
technology in the phone which is also
nice but it's also about the experience
the entire ecosystem of things that make
the tech fun to use and there are a lot
of really good cases for phones out
there that can do exactly that but I
can't really recommend any of them
because I don't personally use cases so
Jon from TLD let us know what's good in
the case world what's up guys Johnson
here and if you are looking to rock a
case I got you covered with a few
options on three of the biggest baddest
smartphones on the planet right now the
iPhone 6 plus the Galaxy Note 4 and of
course the Nexus 6 so one of my
complaints with the iPhone 6 plus is
that it is slippery as hell so if you're
looking to add some grip one of my
favorites is the varus Thor now this
comes in silver gold black electric blue
and hot pink so if you're looking to mix
it up you got some options in addition
to obviously adding grip those four
corners have extra padding so it's gonna
give you maximum shock absorption just
in case you drop that mother
you also get front facing protection the
cutouts and ports are nice and clean and
overall it is a really solid choice for
the iPhone 6 plus
now with the galaxy note 4 by itself and
offers some pretty stellar grip and I
think Samsung has come a long ways with
design so you want to keep it pretty
minimal and pretty lightweight but if
you do want just a little more
protection this is from I blast and it
is their halo series hybrid case and it
comes in for 10 bucks this is made out
of scratch resistant material so if you
work in maybe a rougher environment this
will ensure protection on the back of
your note for last up for the nexus 6
this is from spigen it's our ultra
hybrid series bumper style case and
again just like the Galaxy Note 4 I like
this because it's nice simple and clean
now this comes in a few different colors
this is mint so if you're not rocking a
white Nexus I really like the contrast
that it gives a look it's also gonna add
some pretty solid grip and if you do
drop your phone from time to time like I
admit I do sometimes it's gonna give you
the peace of mind with a little added
protection so now with those case
recommendations here is another tech
accessory to keep your device looking
good without I guess the added bulk of
even the thinnest cases out there you've
probably already guessed it and it's
skins for your phone I am partial to
deep brand skins just for the precision
of fit and the wide variety of devices
they can cover but yeah skins are a
great way to change the look or feel of
a device for way less than 50 bucks and
it really takes your customization to
the next level case in point they have
in the Nexus 6 option that lets you not
only pick the color and the material but
you can pick the cutout on the back to
be either full empty or just leave the X
showing I think that's pretty dope so
I'll have those linked below as well
alright random YouTube chat time so as
far as I can see or sar as I can tell by
watching a lot of people are just
getting started with YouTube or with
video in general focus a lot on the way
the video looks which is great but then
forget about the way the video sounds
and for that reason audio quality on
YouTube tends to be massively underrated
so this guy this little guy will be able
to take care of that for you two USB
microphone it's called the blue snowball
and for 50 bucks you really don't need
to look any further in terms of bringing
your audio quality to the next level
think of your top ten favorite youtubers
I want to guarantee that at least five
of them have used this exact microphone
at some point in one of their videos
that's how popular that's how easily the
vouch for a bowl this thing is you can
ask them they've probably used it so
this thing is very popular and is an
instant upgrade to any cameras built-in
microphones so if you're looking to get
started with YouTube or with making
videos and you've done the audio or
video part of it and want to look at
audio look no further so something else
really high tech is wireless charging
and ever
since I couldn't get the Nexus 6 to work
with the Nexus 5 wireless charger I've
been on the lookout for good ones that
will work and actually by John's
recommendation this is one of them this
is the Aki Luna wireless charger it's
pretty stylish it's not too distracting
it works it charges your devices it's
nice and it's under 50 bucks so it's
linked below so there you go guys those
are my picks for some awesome tech gifts
for either someone you know or something
you want to pick up for yourself I also
did a video called top 5 most
underpriced tech and the things on that
list are a little bit more expensive
than 50 bucks but those are also still
some great deals so if you want some
more variety you can check that out and
the links below are probably just full
of gold there's a ton of links below
this video but definitely all worth
checking out and also check out John's
channel TLD where he is doing something
actually pretty insane and he's
uploading 12 straight days of top 5 tech
deals videos in various different prices
and categories so definitely worth
subscribing to check out the rest of
those when they come out and he's also
giving a bunch of that stuff away so
I'll leave that link below as well check
out the description of this video it's
basically full of gold and links galore
and worth clicking on but either way if
you enjoyed this video or this type of
style of video definitely give it a
thumbs up to let me know or leave a
comment if you have any feedback again
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace